The average movie fan might think that the
story, script, action and drama is everything
a movie is made of.
But sometimes, a movie's greatest moments,
jokes, and meaning can be found in the background,
just waiting for viewers to spot them - and
feel like they're seeing their favorite films
for the very first time.
If you love to watch Hidden Messages videos,
make sure you stick around until the end,
we have a whole series of them!
Before you get to those, here are more of
Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Hidden Messages in
Movies.
Django Unchained
Any fan of classic westerns knows Clint Eastwood's
A Fistful of Dollars, but the 1966 movie Django
is less well known in the West, despite being
famous throughout Europe.
The movie starred Franco Nero as the title
gunslinger, and was considered the most violent
movie ever made when it released.
So it's no surprise it inspired Quentin Tarantino,
among other directors, who would name the
star of his own western after Nero's character.
Nero even makes a cameo in Django Unchained.
He's officially playing a different character,
but when he asks the former slave how his
name is spelled, the audience gets a one of
a kind reference that will fly over most of
their heads.
Hot Fuzz
Edgar Wright made sure that the movies of
his "Cornetto Trilogy" would be linked by
stars Simon Pegg and Nick Frost, but there
are too many small connections to count.
One of the best can be spotted in Hot Fuzz,
when Frost's character is sifting through
DVDs in a grocery store.
Look fast, and you can spot the unmistakable
cover of Shaun of the Dead, the trio's previous
film - with a price tag planted over Pegg's
face . The movie apparently exists in Hot
Fuzz's universe, since the title "Zombie's
Party" was actually the movie's title in foreign
markets.
Indiana Jones
Fans might never have noticed that the villain
of the third Indiana Jones movie first appeared
as an Imperial officer in The Empire Strikes
Back, played by actor Julian Glover, but they
probably should have, thanks to a clever gag
from director Steven Spielberg.
Long before the character is revealed to be
up to no good, he meets with Indy to discuss
the Holy Grail.
But pay attention to the music coming in from
the party outside, and you'll hear a lighter
take on Darth Vader's Imperial March.
It's an awesome nod to the actor's previous
role, but an even funnier hint that he wasn't
to be trusted.
Gravity
This survival story set in Earth's orbit took
a few liberties with its physics, but got
more right than it did wrong.
That's largely thanks to astronaut Andy Thomas,
who used his multiple space flights as a consultant
for the cast and crew.
For his hard work, Thomas earned a funny,
but dark homage, listed as one of the deceased
members of the Explorer's mission.
But that wasn't all: the Australian-born astronaut
got a nod to his homeland in the form of a
"Kangaroo Crossing" sticker slyly planted
in the movie's version of the International
Space Station.
Iron Man 3
Tony Stark's former chauffeur showed he has
a sophisticated side when a run-in with a
superpowered soldier sent him into the hospital.
But the reveal that Happy Hogan was a Downton
Abbey fan was far more than it seemed.
The scene being shown features the characters
Branson and Sybill - or put simply, a wealthy
young woman and a chauffeur.
A perfect storyline, since the Marvel Comics
universe saw the chauffeur fall in love with
a wealthy young woman: Pepper Potts.
I Am Legend
You don't think of background jokes or secret
humor when it comes to I am Legend, but Robert
Neville found plenty of clever ways to keep
himself busy as the only human left alive
(in New York, at least).
But take a closer look at his house and you'll
notice he's used the lack of security to indulge
his love of art, decorating the walls with
priceless paintings, including Vincent Van
Gogh's "Starry Night".
The best part is that not all of them are
fake: the movie's hero had to steal them from
New York's Museum of Modern Art, but the real
world museum actually let the filmmakers use
some of their prized possessions in the movie.
Apparently, it was too good a joke for them
to pass up.
Wreck-it it Ralph
Disney's trip inside the world of video games
packed in all kinds of famous cameos, but
the animators showed they were serious, hardcore
arcade gamers, if the grafitti is anything
to go by.
There's the messages referring to the Warcraft
legend Leroy Jenkins, and a hopeful promise
for Final Fantasy fans that "Aerith Lives".
But the most inside joke comes with the tag
"Sheng Long Was Here".
The Street Fighter character began as an April
Fool's Joke in EGM, sending fans everywhere
chasing the urban legend for years.
But in Game Central Station, the hope is still
alive.
Saving Private Ryan
Steven Spielberg was careful not to glamorize
any part of World War 2, but after seeing
the nearly half hour sequence of American
soldiers charging Omaha Beach, losing countless
men in the process, it's hard to not be satisfied
when they finally break through the German
lines, and start turning the battle in their
favor.
But Spielberg concealed another tragic moment
in that victory.
When two German soldiers come out with hands
up to surrender, their please of mercy are
ignored, and they're shot where they stand.
What they were actually saying: "don't shoot,
I didn't kill anyone, I'm Czech," implying
they were men taken prisoner when Germany
occupied their homeland, and forced to man
the front lines - making an ugly moment even
more tragic.
Furious 7
Dwayne The Rock Johnson unfortunately spent
most of the movie in a hospital room, but
he didn't let that keep him out of the fight
entirely.
But what was Hobbs doing all that time in
bed?
One scene reveals that he's taking in a football
game, before the action is interrupted by
breaking news.
But take a closer look at the sack being made
by "Number 94".
It's no random game, it’s the showdown between
the University of Miami and Florida State
in 1991.
The defensive tackle making the sack?
None other than Johnson himself at age 19.
His season would end due to injury, but considering
how his career turned out, we don't think
it's a touchy subject.
Skyfall
In the world of super spy James Bond, everyone
has a codename.
There's Moneypenny, Q, and the woman in charge,
“M”.
Judi Dench's version of the fearless leader
has held the title for longer than most, even
when the series was recast and rebooted with
star Daniel Craig.
But her real name was never revealed - or
was it?
When Skyfall's final act saw her killed in
the field, she left James one of her prized
possessions.
But take a closer look at the outside of the
box: she didn't sign with her codename, but
her real one - Olivia Mansfield.
Turns out the "M" was more fitting than fans
realized.
Those are the best hidden messages and meanings
we could find in movies, but which ones have
we missed?
Be sure to tell us in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!
Click on the on-screen link for more Hidden
Messages videos!
Thanks!